rely on your critics that an amateur
built the ark experts built the Titanic
I always loved the game when Dad loved
to play he just taught me to play the
game for the love of the game and that's
really what I do there were other
players who were more talented but there
was no one who could out prepare me I
mean we all speak regular Gaelic paints
counted into his own thing you know
he's a former American football
quarterback who played 18 seasons in the
NFL he's considered to be one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time he's
the only starting quarterback to win a
Super Bowl with two different franchises
he's Peyton Manning and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite I
make sure to stick around all over to
the end for some special bonus clips and
as always the Peyton says something
that's really really meaningful to you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it as he's talking
so that other people can be inspired as
well
so don't let expertise silence you work
to find new solutions to old problems
think outside the parameters that
restrict other people's thoughts just
because you're a novice on the job just
because you haven't faced the same
challenges just because you haven't
climbed the same cliffs doesn't mean
that you can't contribute to solutions
in very significant ways when you're
chided for your naivete and you will be
remind your critics that an amateur
built the art experts built the Titanic
I think the fact that that injury
occurred to me has just given me more an
appreciation for this journey that I'm
on and I have had fun
this entire playoff run I have tried to
soak it up I haven't just been so laser
focused and where I haven't enjoyed
anything we you know we've had two good
post playoff win celebrations but give
it a good run after San Diego and a
really good run after New England and so
I think that's some advice that some
players in their older years gave to me
and I really tried to follow that and I
plan to enjoy this week as well but a
great week of preparation last week it's
important this week but I do think it's
important to to soak it up and as they
say enjoy the journey not just the
destination I learned a valuable lesson
when I was a freshman at Tennessee that
I applied to my first year on the job in
the NFL it was the first time I ran into
the huddle as a quarterback at Tennessee
we were playing up at UCLA in the Rose
Bowl 95 thousand people in the stands
ABC broadcast in the game on national
television Keith Jackson and Bob Griese
Tennessee was ranked ninth in the
country UCLA was unranked expected to be
a blowout I was third team on the depth
chart not expecting to play the entire
game much less the entire season on the
seventh play of the game our starting
quarterback tears his knee he's out for
the year
our backup quarterback was a guy named
todd helton who went on to have an
18-year major league baseball career
let's just say todd was kind of thinking
about that baseball signing bonus he was
about to get he wasn't real crazy about
going into the game so we're getting b21
than nothing
my coach turns me and says Peyton you're
going in and boy I didn't think how
reservist look down and all the
Harriman's just sticking straight up so
I'm jogging into that huddle and I
remember something that my daddy told me
he said son if you ever get into the
huddle
with the starters at any point in the
season it may be in the fourth quarter
of a blowout it may be just in practice
it doesn't matter you be the leader and
you take control that home that's your
job as the quarterback you're just 18
years old most of these seniors are 21
22 it doesn't matter
be the leader and take control that
huddle so I remembered old dad's advice
and I get into that huddle and I said
all right guys I know I'm just a
freshman but I could take us down the
field right now get us a touchdown and
get us back in this game let's go big
left tackle guy named Jason layman about
65 330 pounds grabs you by the shoulder
and says hey freshman shut the blank up
and call the blank and play and I said
yes sir I was really great advice for my
dad I really well I've always had a
passion for the game but when you are
out for a year you certainly miss
certain things being in that huddle
flying back on the plane after a big
victory the weight room and after
practice throwing sessions with you
receivers they're going to make a
difference and help you win a game on
Sunday you just go you just don't get to
participate in those activities when
you're not playing and you're injured so
to get back out on the field I have more
of an appreciation for the little things
everybody enjoys playing football in the
games but I have more of an appreciation
for the small details the things that
you don't that you won't get to do after
you stop playing football so those those
moments have been even more special in
my very first NFL game I completed my
first pass to Hall of Fame running back
Marshall Falls I threw a touchdown in
that same game to Marvin Harris
and would be inducted into the Hall of
Fame that's August the quarterback for
our opponent the Miami Dolphins was
after my dad my favorite player
hall-of-famer Dan Marino who on the
first third down of the game completed a
25-yard skinny post and it was the
damnedest throw I'd ever seen
later I completed a pass to tight in
Marcus Pollard down the middle and
somebody hit me really hard and after I
got up I told myself I know I can play
in this league later in that struggling
season we played in and lost to
Baltimore it was the first time that the
Colts had returned to Baltimore since
they had moved back in 1984 we didn't
exactly get a warm reception that day
fans were screaming at me and I kept
thinking hey I was only eight years old
then get off of my back I had met him
once before but when the game was over I
had a chance to shape Johnny Unitas his
hand he told me Payton you stay at it
I'm pulling for you well I have stayed
at it I've stayed at it for 18 years and
I hope that old number 19 is up there
with his flattop and maybe his black
high tops on and I hope he knows that I
have stayed at it and maybe he's even a
little proud of me
it's all about money it's all let's get
out and play and make the millions out
because you know you don't know what
could happen in that final year right
that's kind of the norm now people take
the money and go pro but just growing up
around college football I always love
the game and dad loved to play he just
taught me to play the game for the love
of the game and that's really what I do
I like to play the game and I want to
come back and play another year college
football good for you and I told our
editors Chris stone and Paul faked in
balm a story about last year after one
of the most crushing defeats of your
career right here in this stadium
against the Baltimore Ravens that you
waited for about 15 minutes afterwards
with your wife and with your son for Ray
Lewis to come out why did you do that
well Ray Lewis has been the greatest
defensive player that I've ever played
against
knew that was going to be his last game
and you just don't cross paths with
those players once they stopped playing
so it was definitely a disappointing
night but I thought it was the
appropriate thing to do to go over and
pay respect to one of the greatest
defensive players of all time and the
best player of my era and took the
moment and I was glad that I did it you
know it's I played the Ravens this year
it wasn't the same not seeing number 52
over there I haven't seen him since that
moment and realized that I won't see him
quite as often so I guess that was an
example of sportsmanship
it certainly wasn't easy and I can
promise you that but I was glad that I
did it because I thought he deserved my
respects and I look back on my NFL
career I'll know without a doubt and I
gave everything I had to help my team's
walk away with a win there were other
players who are more talented but there
was no one who could out prepare me and
because of that I have no regrets
there's a scripture reading second
Timothy 4:7 I have fought the good fight
and I have finished the race I have kept
the faith well I fought a good fight I
finished my football race and after 18
years it's time god bless all of you and
God bless football hard hits are not I
don't believe there's any way to over
prepare for your future have a formula
plan have a back-up plan and have a
backup to your backup plan my
preparation begins by watching game tape
of our team and competitors it helps me
put the pieces of the puzzle together
years ago I had a system put in my house
where I could analyze every game every
competitor without having to go into the
team's practice facility so if you ask
me how long do i watch game film to
prepare I couldn't tell you because I've
never kept a clock I just watch until I
feel ready I watch and I prepare I could
actually get lost in the intense focus
of figuring things out that others may
never
even look at if you really want to be a
game changer out there become a master
observer just the willingness to stop
and look at things that no one else has
even bothered to look at enables game
changers to identify real points of
meaning the simple process of focusing
on things that are normally taken for
granted can be a source of great power
and creativity I'm a naturally curious
person I want to know and thoroughly
understand things we learn we observed
we'd pick up on clues we figure things
out
that is what preparation is all about
manning uses a rare form of gaelic at
the line of scrimmage I mean we all
speak regular Gaelic paints kind of into
his own thing you know
it takes me forever to translate it core
3 hi how do you decipher any of it well
he's been sticking his hand at my butt
for 11 years so we're pretty close see
my brother Cooper actually is the one
that taught me Gaelic he's really into
it it's got a personalized license plate
what does it say like mr. Gaelic or son
only what my brother this Gaelic stuff's
awesome
but I like to mix it up every now and
then a lot of times I just say whatever
comes to mind
bacon bacon bacon hot sauce hot sauce
chick taco taco I don't know what that
means
bacon bacon bacon I don't know what the
guys talking about most of the time I
just run an out route just hope he
throws it to me like chili chili chili
what taco chick taco taco a lot of times
Kimmy we have no idea what we're doing
but the defense doesn't know that we
don't know what we're doing that's next
level cross clock up hot sauce hot sauce
3 3 ain't garlic bacon chili chili chili
teeth
come on guys right
ice-cream alert 654 Jose Peyton Manning
and the Colts when the NFL's most
sophisticated offense each play can be
called or changed at the line that
forces the Colts linemen to wait and
wait until Peyton finally makes up his
mind I wonder if they ever think just
snap the damn ball here's goals not to
get the perfect play is to have a bad
play and more times about to do that
Peyton drops looks fired it's a ballet
that drives people crazy you know as you
say just snap the damn ball they'll do
it when they're damn well pleased
it started way back you know I guess my
last second year with Tom more we kind
of sat down and just put some some code
words together and things that kind of
made sense but it just taken off for
that purple purple Buddha writers it's
not about trickery but it does take
constant communication because when you
do change a pass play to Iran run flight
to a pass play it's not easy to just say
let's throw it it's I say something and
then you tell the offensive line and
they have an entirely different language
it's unbelievable what these guys go
through about a what go ahead and block
if you don't have Lyme and that are
smart they can like I've said comprehend
inaudible with five seconds make their
calls call east/west Dumbo you name it
these orders that you know where these
words come from what other business
requires using words Bonanza I mean that
really doesn't mean anything but could
be a call that we use it's not so much
the coach that needs to know what we're
talking about it's the players I need to
talk to one another so we leave a lot of
their code words and calls and that sort
of thing up to them hold on before you
gather we have to call bogus on Howard
Mudd saying he's not involved
somebody spoke that man is involved in
every part of every call we will ever
make they need to be smart and they need
to be tough minded tough minded in that
you know they may only get a piece of
the information or they didn't get any
of the information I remember in Kansas
City in the playoff game the left law
tonight neither of us knew the play and
we couldn't hear we just kind of wrap it
everything turned out great the way we
talked about it is you have to hear
there's not an option at interior
if somebody doesn't hear I really feel
responsible that's why I was gonna go
back for a second time go down the line
just to make sure everybody knows what
to do because you know one guy done here
that guy misses the block and we have a
bad play you could read through it in
your playbook as much as you want but
you're not gonna understand it and tell
you out there on the field but actually
here to come out of the quarterbacks
mouth there are times when he calls a
real play and then changes it there are
times when he calls a phony play to
extract a reaction before we call a real
play then we have the fake play real
play and then change the real play
Desalle 1919 Sally
I like that he's changing the play
because when he changed the play the
defense sees us you know looking at him
or looking to Jeff or whoever and
they're just as confused I mean they
don't know when the balls gonna be
snapped so a lot of times they kind of
relax a little bit a way for us to get
you know done communicating you get a
lot of guessing I mean they're trying to
guess what play will run in
instrumental our calls all when they do
this this is what they did
if I were a defender listening to our
calls wouldn't be one of the big things
for me because he's just one of those
guys they he'll fake it or he does is
low gymnastics back there and you know
defenses bite so the whole listen to the
words hasn't worked yet really we don't
see lot of them because he's
orchestrating behind us but we hear from
other people like family and friends
alike Heil what is that I think about
quarterbacks and their defining legacy
you think about Dan Marino it's just the
quick buoys from Elway it's the sprint
right throw back across left Montana is
the classic almost within the two-minute
drives
for me I think it's gonna be you know
this you know you know pick my nose you
know this all these different things
that I do I don't want that to be my
legacy but that is what we have to do
and you constantly having to do
something either to tell the center
something tell the Titans tell the
receiver to tell the box
it's what is required with the
quarterback to get things communicated
it's an amazing compilation of people
and schemes and it works people say just
stamp the damn ball but again if you
look at the track record since paints
been here it's been a great
orchestration that's work because the
cult's can be more reactive at the line
than other teams maybe changing the play
they take fewer risks and score more
touchdowns and birds that will be the
legacy of Peyton Manning and his
offensive
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I made this video
because our Toro mega asked me to so if
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it down in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from Peyton today what was your favorite
clip what message was most meaningful to
you what are you gonna apply to your
business leave in the comments below and
I'm gonna join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout out to Ben
stuck Ben thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book it really really
really means a lot to me so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourselves and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I thought it was very interesting when I
saw you here at training camp this
summer one of the things I said to you I
asked you a question
what do you think you'd be doing in 15
years and you wouldn't answer the
question and I thought it was so
interesting why wouldn't you answer that
question well I think maybe had you
asked me two years ago I might have had
more of an idea but like I said these
past two years have have truly changed
my life and so I'm really in a new place
and kind of in the second chapter of my
football career and I'm taking that
chapter one page at a time and so it
feels so good to be back out onto the
field playing this great game and I
realized after that injury I think I
always have realized this but it was
something reinforced that next year
certainly is not promised and so I am
all in for 2013 and I'm certainly
enjoying this year crawfish shorts I
like your style
epic comeback starts right here
lucky shot she wore the number 18 but he
is the number one in all time passing
yards the number one in all time passing
touchdowns
one in the smoke machine is really cool
yeah it's pretty great it's Morse month
hurry shall we say grace
Heavenly Father she had the perfect
family
an adoring husband I smile I don't know
I'm just happy and an ideal life but she
also had a dark secret she liked to
collect football players
you have any place to stay tonight
yes have a place to stay don't you dare
lie to me lady I'm not lying I'm Peyton
Manning I'm a couple of homes
oh are you freaking out and now this
quarterback Oh Sean says all the pro
athletes use futons if they can't find a
bed big enough but I got you something
nicer he's in a game of life and death
I've never had one before bought a room
to yourself know a crazy lady holding me
against my will
award-winners Sandra Bullock
I feel like this is serious and
four-time NFL MVP Peyton Manning the
crazy lady is holding prisoner for house
big mine
it's call me Big Mike stop laughing it's
not funny was she crazy about football
or just crazy another thing we need to
find out more about his past he won't
talk about it
he's like an onion you have to feeling
back a layer at a time not if you use a
knife
get in her way Michael needs to be what
does he have to do to deserve that first
of all his name's not Michael and he's
very clearly NFL quarterback Peyton
Manning that would be him and second of
all I can't give him a B because of how
badly he's doing in class let me read
you his essay about A Tale of Two Cities
help please help me call the police I'm
Peyton Manning and I've been kidnapped
by the lady from speed
we're sunk no you're sunk because you
see I have contacted the authorities and
they are oh my god where's my father
single film Archie Manning called
terrify Tony Dungy says each
spine-tingling
and Bill Belichick raves it's hilarious
we want to know if you would like to
become part of this family yes you kids
something she kidnapped you as well
and if I say no something terrible's
gonna happen to me
so I guess my best bet is just to
pretend another teenager even though I'm
34 I'm in
how's he doing
I've been quite getting the hang of it
yet since I'm playing offensive line I'm
a quarterback
so I love
never Hey
your vanity was likely
the dark side